all right um K
Hall K Hall is a in Modern English I
would call a micro drill which
means it is drilling for a
singular or a very reduced amount of
skills or
aspects
um versus a drill like you're doing a
drill uh like kihon waza there's lots of
aspects in it or
scenario even more okay so koku hold
micro drilling for
C uh
CQ is a type of force engine I'm I'm
going to try to use modern terms for
people
who not have not experienced it don't
know what it is and have been misled by
a lot of Bido people who do not have C
and cannot manifest
CQ it's a type of force
engine uh in particular it's a
rebounding Force engine
so
um not a rebounding Force engine let's
say like a a propelling force engine
would be like boom a punch a rebounding
engine would be more like when he hits
my fist and then he bounces off of
it in terms of Yin
Yong it is his y aspect
that I am going to
internalize allow to pass through
me
hit the
Earth come back through me and hit him
that's the rebounding just to put it
simply it's a rebounding Force
engine
okay in
iido the way that iido uses it
is you're going to see there is a lot of
Yin external movements that will set up
the rebounding Force engine okay so for
example
um I'm not going to sit here and uh just
push him over with a propelling
engine but I I also won't just sit here
and try to project him you're going to
see that I'm going to do a Yin
movement and then I'll rebound off of
him
here so as he's coming in I'm going to
yield and he'll hit that there okay so
it looks something like
this you're going to see that all the
time in all of your once you see it once
you know what it is so uh let's say he's
doing some pushing same thing
here I'm going to clear it and you're
going to see it again it's over here so
you see a yield and then a rebound
boom once you see it you should be able
to see it everywhere okay so it doesn't
have to be with him grabbing me it
doesn't have to be with me grabbing him
it doesn't have to be be on the arms or
anything like that okay and it doesn't
have to be with my hands either so some
example of Not My Cross not my hands is
here's his movement he I'm going to
yield and then I'll bounce them off of
my body so
boom okay or you have your
throws here right it's now not in his
wrist it's going to be on his neck he
bounces off a
[Music]
bit same exact thing there's going to be
a yield and you can think of it as the
yield loads the rebounding tactic
okay so when we were doing M two hand
grab and we're doing this technique
where we're coming
around there's your
yield so I'm going to
yield and as he comes in I'm loading the
rebounding so this not like the throw
not like the throw in the video I just
want you to see the rebound I'm going to
yield it comes around
boom so
the rebound happens right on his Center
Line it's not
over where you're doing a kind of like e
this way
no and there's no need to bend my elbow
and cut him down the yield of the Iden
con did it so you notice that in the
first video my arm never bends there's
no need to bend it the
yielding
tactic was in the movement of the body
and the arm opening up
okay even when I went straight
up as my arm goes up that's the yielding
tactic and that's what it
is I don't need to bend my
elbow push him down that's a propulsion
engine okay so to use the rebound engine
I'm going to use my movement and my arm
to set up the
rebounding engine so I'm moving
around okay now for the
throw let's say he's pushing at me he's
never going to get in with the with the
c you I I can hold it here so I'm going
to let it go up you see let Hiser CER
come up just so slightly and then the
rebounding is here on his
chest back past his
stance so you're going to let him
up and then this is loading
here no different than this one loading
here that's the I I
want this one just let It Center up
and that's where you rebound there so
you have the Dr there's the
yield you have the T C let him hit
it and you have to let their Center
through so you can't be here Center
never come through I could rebound from
here but he'll just go straight out so
in the yield it goes up the center comes
through and that's where the rebounding
engine hits so let's say he's here
I'm going to let It Center up stay there
imagine they let their Center up by
letting it go through and then the
rebounding
energy pushes there but it's not that
would be a propulsion engine what I want
is a re
out and you see my arm is
straight
okay let's
try Okay common
mistakes your rebounding
energy is only going to
be as
projecting as you
absorbed and that is a difficult part
for people because they don't want they
don't want to have it come in but you
have to let it come in okay the more it
comes in the more you can store it the
more you can project it so in terms of
Yin and
Yong the more Yin the more
y the less y the less y so for example
if I don't let him in there's not much
projection even if I am going to do it
internally so I won't let them in it's
small
well if I let him in it
stores
okay so in this
throw you not only want to obey the rule
that the more you absorb the more you
can
project but in order to get the kazushi
I need his Center to come forward of his
head that way he's in this
position and my rebounding energy even
though my arm is here I'm rebounding at
this point where he's contacting boom
into that line that rebounding energy is
going
there so I I have to let him
in and then
project it's not that I'm cutting down
on
here when you see my hand drop it's
because it was relaxed and he his hands
went down so I'll try to keep my
up and you can see that the projection
already happened what you see at the end
is
that because there's nothing holding it
up any okay so don't try to cut him down
so there's no need to bend your elbow
and let them in
more now if this is your
kazushi you're going to get the hips
forward and you're going to push the
chest down at this with that rebounding
energy this
Vector if you miss glancing this way you
get something else glancing that way you
get something else if it goes straight
back you get something else so you
rebounding energy just can't go wherever
it has to
go into the
angle that's going to do this throw so
if I go to the side it'll turn him okay
not to the side even as you tank on here
let him come around into it the tank con
version is nothing different than the
ult version I'm still in front of him so
I'm going to tank con and he comes
around there it is right
there like all your UDA versions okay
you do the
spiral
there okay you just wait for him to come
back onto the
line okay try it
again okay so if we're down
here and I'm going to do that yield to
load the rebound me
boom it doesn't mean that I'm going like
that meaning if I go like this he and he
he was pushing on me which is what the
energy the young energy that I rebound
it if he's pushing on me fast it's not
going to
work so the Yang energy that he has I
still take it through the yin phase of
my movement so he can't push on me this
arm is not going to get here so that way
his whole body is affected even on the
yin
movement
okay so when you're doing this it's not
that I go up it's not going to work okay
he's pushing me and I'm slowly re
angling that up it's not that I just
lift up and go like
this I'm here and I'm going to lift
slowly letting him come under with no
wet noodle arm such that as my arm is
here can't push me over he can't push me
over he can't push me over he can't push
me over he can't push me over you
understand but some of you are just
lifting and then hoping his Center gets
there it's not going to get there that
way okay so I come
around and I
control even at this weird angle he
tries to
push he's it's grounded here he's
pushing that way doesn't
matter so don't just go here like
this that's different does that look
different there's extension boom you
will feel that and that although it's
not rebounding yet it's being stored and
he feels that feels that the entire time
there's no even though it's a Yin
external he doesn't feel the
retreating and I am
incrementally releasing the bottom for
him not just getting out of the way so
that his Center comes forward do you
understand
okay some will
see like a
Niko and then he's taking Kem by getting
out of the way of the pain that's not
what's
happening there is there is no ni you
can let go you see it doesn't
matter just like if we were doing a n
when I'm here I don't have to get on
this side to project him
out I can be here on top and still
project he can let go and I still can
project
so don't search for the
lock search for the stored energy stored
energy stored energy stored energy
letting his Center through and then
V and hence it's now Kul I'm working on
the rebounding Force engine that's all
I'm
doing
okay K go so in a rebounding energy I
want to absorb his energy the more I
absorb the more that comes back out okay
and uh the more you
Propel the less you
absorb
okay and the more you Propel after you
project the propulsion energy will take
over from the absorption energy okay so
here to get off of uh the
a Niko I'm telling you it's not Niko
we're going to come here okay if you
Propel your arm you'll slip through his
grip okay so because it's important
because that's the IU phase of C so I'm
I'm sticking in his arm by his energy
that's coming in and me neither
retreating from it nor contesting it I
just sit there
neutral and do the same technique
so doesn't matter if you're on the
inside you got to do the same thing
though you can't just push back you have
to let them
in to find the angle it's the same
relaxed
arm okay we're on the inside to get rid
of the temptation of pushing on the
apparent Niko but there is no Niko that
okay as a micro drill it's a Twan drill
so his spinal
penetration is what
generates the Yang energy that I
internalize that I accumulate that I
will eventually rebound okay um but a
lot of the UK get scared because their
body can't understand it okay and that
actually works for you as long as you
don't let their
fear through contagion come into you
Their Fear comes into you you'll project
you'll you'll Propel okay you have to
stay relaxed they'll be confused by
what's happening their body will tense
and that's young energy okay cuz fear is
that young energy okay so it actually
works for you but you're going to first
feel their fear and it will have you
want to be fearful and you will do a
propulsion okay so uh let's say he's you
can see that he's really pushing but you
go here and he kind of stopped he
stopped on you okay I'm actually
stopping him if you pay
attention I can feel the weight of my
feet and I can feel the weight on my arm
even though he he's not doing the same
spinal penetration so it's the same Yang
energy it's just at a lower level so I
will go ahead and uh adjust my body for
what he's doing so for example there's
less jogs okay we'll do the Tenon
one okay or I can
yield to get him to come in his
intention is to grab me but my grab's
not there in space I'll make my grab
over here in space but it's time to
ish you can see came in even deeper than
he expected but if I try to do that
quickly they'll let go because I am
responding with the same fear so you'll
feel it you'll feel what you'll
[Music]
feel
that was a lot of
young you can't even go
forward that's a
matter not much go
forward
yield you all
right right yeah y small
Big
[Music]
10 Big Head Cons with
yields Big 10 Cons with me
[Music]
doesn't
matter doesn't matter okay it's all a
feeling of storing the energy rebounding
the energy all right let's try so
another way of thinking about how I just
I'm kind of Shaving off the top of the
Yang energy so that the center comes
forward another way of thinking about it
is that I let him lift my hand so as I
go like that he keeps coming forward
he's pushing my hand forward d i don't
lift my hand I'm not here trying to take
my hand up that would be a Yin movement
that as I go up he would be able to
shove it in nope you'd bring your hand
up bring your hand up bring your hand up
bring your hand up I would be able to do
it to him okay so instead he's pushing I
keep changing the angle and he now
brought my hand up I didn't lift my hand
up I'm not coming backwards and yielding
externally you understand so as I come
in he lifts my hand
up but that will let his Center come
forward do not lift your hand up there's
no going backwards in this idea okay try
it again okay remember that the internal
aspects are
in modern terms we' probably call them
uh psycho
physical I would just say they're
spiritual
aspects your desire to throw them will
stop you from absorbing the yin
aspect so your fear of not throwing them
is going to codependent arise your
desire to throw them and you will not be
able to internalize the Yang aspect you
will and therefore you will not have a
rebounding energy you just have arm
propulsion so likewise especially people
who who can't uh have no experience with
the rebounding
energy or have been misled from other
modern I DOA that c is my hands are
shaking Sensei it's all right we give
it so for those who have never
experienced
a rebounding energy or for those who
have been misled into believing koku is
going to be something
else
um it's hard for them to believe this
but even in the belief of
it you can hear their lust for power
because it makes them
angry because they think that someone
would be all powerful with such a
skill so they can't first accept that
it's just a drill for cultivating
rebound energy martially you would use
rebounding energy alongside propelling
energy in any of the martially viable
tactical architectures that you'd have
Kokyo is not
that so when they watch it they they
imagine
that what you're doing is all powerful
but in your desire to be all powerful
which is inside your anger at seeing
someone thrown by some way you can't
understand
you can you can't do it it's taken from
you so as you're practicing
it I'll give you the following things to
help govern you into the
form the first thing is a physical
thing do not move your back
foot at no point move your back
foot
once you get that don't move your front
foot or your back
foot and the second thing is the kind of
meditation that you'll do at every
single
rep you're going to not want to
throw as soon as you feel the desire
arise you're going to let it
go
and once you get
that I want you to monitor for muscle
tension if you become sensitive enough
to your desire to throw and your
subsequent codependent arising fear you
can now start to feel the muscle tension
that is actually stopping you from
internalizing the Y energy that you want
to
rebound so every time you do the throw
you have to make yourself desireless so
you have to make a problem out of the
desire to throw you have to make a
problem out of the desire to become
powerful